your longtime rival Anderson Silva and
you're a gentleman I you don't need to
play the gentleman card it's not there
not enough people listening here just
tested positive now for two banned
steroids what do you make of that
there's a lot of speculation going on
what was your initial reaction when you
heard it well just to put it in
perspective for everybody that maybe
doesn't follow the news on the Anderson
as you're speaking of but we're about 12
hours into this whole thing so my
opinion and your opinion we need to
reserve the right to change our opinion
when we're confronted with new evidence
which is certainly going to happen as
this thing continues on but you know
look there's there's two sides to this
here there's there's two parts of at
least first off and again a quick
timeline for everybody
Anderson Silva had what's known as a
compound fracture in his leg right his
leg snapped me the bone had a clean
break in half the only thing that kept
his shin and his foot connected to his
body was his skin right as graphic as
that sounds it's very relevant to this
now Anderson has an obligation a moral
obligation to himself to put his health
first he needs to do whatever he can to
repair that leg I think we could all
stipulate to that whether it's free
market or black market if it helps his
leg even if he's got a lien on science
good for him okay path however there the
second part of it is sport
there are rules within the sport and
they have to be followed no matter what
it's real black and white and you don't
you don't often get to come to the table
and go well yeah but there there is a
reason for that you don't get to do that
right it sounds as though he took
something that's banned it sounds as
though it's an illegal steroid and he's
gonna have to answer for that so it's a
little bit of a two-part thing well done
one second go as you just mentioned
something that you and I have talked
about I've heard you mentioned before a
lot of people don't understand right and
we'll get into the fact because a lot of
people will say well chill it can't
compliment us he's a hypocrite we'll get
into that but the difference between a
banned substance and an illegal steroid
what he was taking to the best of my
understanding at least one of those
substances wasn't
illegal steroid am i right wrong and
what's the difference according to what
he's accused of yes he had I believe it
was two things in his system I believe
they are both illegal steroids to my
understand in America he came from South
America again there could be some
conversation on laws there but by our
standards and my understanding yes
that's correct good thing I will say
having read up on the drugs that
Anderson did use you know one of those
substances if you look at it actually
one of its symptoms what one of the side
effects is that it can cause over
calcification it can actually cause
bones to become weaker and more prone to
breaking did you know that no I had
heard that and that's where you have all
of the you know people speculating and
again it is speculation you have a bunch
of mouth breathers who've never had an
armbar in their life on Sherdog acting
like they're now medical experts or
biochemists but that is an actual side
effect of that one drug that he had
taken which sort of makes it interesting
I know listen you hate to ever drag
someone's name through the mud obviously
you've had some things happen but it is
a little bit fun as a news unfolds let's
be honest you know I'll tell you this
about myself I I was asked that too I
would soon as you test positive for
something people will want to say it was
over your your whole career and my
response is that's fair that's a fair
statement if you get hit with something
it runs you all the way back in time
right the reality is as science and
medicine change you're constantly taking
new things are they within the rules or
not you know I think that's all a good
question nobody's totally clear on what
these rules are I don't think you are I
knew prior to Anderson testing positive
how to pronounce these substances let
alone where they allowed or not so you
kind of learn as you go but I do think
that's a fair statement you know I don't
think a guy should I don't think it
helps a guy to ever come out of go no no
no this was a one-time or or I only did
our man they just caught me in a bed
just call it what it is man you took it
you got caught the end and that that's
what happened we'll see how Anderson
handles it but I think when somebody at
least for me when somebody tried to say
things even if it wasn't accurate I
think I still deserve it if you test
positive and somebody wants to run that
back all the way to when I started my
they're nine years old I don't think
that guy's wrong do you think Anderson
was
on something when you fought them I can
tell you I can tell you on the substance
issues the the rules get very blurred
and it'll tell you why they have
something now called out of competition
testing write it the rule used to be in
the rule when I started and came through
and one of the problems I have was not
adapting to the changes but it used to
just be in competition meaning what's in
your system on fight night time matter
if you were to come in and go hey listen
I got to tell you guys when I was in
high school I did and then fill in the
blank they go out we don't care you know
well bad news when I was in college I
did it again the guy we don't care so
right off the bat you understand time
does matter there is a time period of
which all is forgiven
right the confusion has come in what is
that time period and I accept that these
are the rules and we must operate within
them I do believe there's a conversation
to be had that you can't just ban all
medication from a person a person does
not had one second one second please
help or I hate to do this but the
question was do you believe do you think
someone else a gun to your head do you
think Anderson had used before or
anything this is a one-time deal when
you fought him do you think he was on
something if you have to guess what he I
can't answer with a yes or no Stephen
because here's why here's why the if
you're saying that a guy never took a
banned substance in his life that's a
silly statement particularly in the
context of you and I just established
that tylenol caffeine IV prep these
things are all banned substances but
what about these substances that he was
taking you know I really don't know me
and I can tell you this on Anderson
Silva that the human body doesn't get
better with age right that's reality we
start to decline as humans and
particularly as athletes right around 25
years old if you're real lucky you might
push that to 27 or 28 the good news is
science and medicine have come along and
decided the world does not belong to 18
to 25 year olds but that you can extend
your career right beyond so if you're
asking me if he took something there's
two tests that you take Stephen the
first
first test is not alright the urine drug
test the first test is the visual when a
guy takes his t-shirt off and gets into
the ring or steps on the scale you look
at it if a guy got better with time you
can't do that on your own Anderson
Silva's body doesn't appear to have
changed at all
so a reasonable person would conclude
that whatever he was on now he was on
before but there's no evidence to
support that so that ticked me off again
Chris is a good friend of mine he
trained me
we were we were partners on stars aren't
stripes we became great friends from
there and we